[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
get inside here go go go
new updates in the uvalde texas school
shooting as body cam footage and a
preliminary report of an investigation
into the massacre are released plus 26
years after her disappearance the
accused killer of california college
student kristen smart stands trial and
did you ever know mr eastman to be a
jealous man
no
the state rests as the defense begins
making its case in the trial of colorado
versus kevin dean eastman but first
hello
my name is nick i'm going to be the next
school shooter of 2018.
my goal is at least 20 people it's going
to be a big event
and when you see me on the news
you'll know who i am prosecutors present
opening statements in the long-awaited
florida sentencing phase trial of the
parkland school shooter long crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer more than
four years after the parkland school
shooter murdered 17 students and staff
members at marjory stoneman douglas high
school the trial to determine his
sentencing begins law and crimes angela
levy was in the courtroom for the
prosecutor's opening statement
prosecutor michael satz laid out in
excruciating detail what nicholas cruz
did on valentine's day 2018 when he
walked into marjory stoneman douglas
high school and killed 17 students and
staff members
i'm going to speak to you
about the unspeakable
about this defendant
goal directed
planned
systematic murder
mass murder
of 14 children
an athletic director
a teacher
and a coach
sats described crews moving methodically
through the school killing students
including jamie guttenberg and meadow
pollock he said it was undeniable that
crews planned the attack
family members bowing their heads at
times as they listened to the details
crews sitting at the defense table
wearing a mask emotionless sat said that
crews went to a walmart after the
shooting and ordered an icy
three days
before these brutal murder this massacre
the defendant in this case
made a cell phone video on his cell
phone
and this is what the defendant said
hello my name is nick
i'm going to be
the next school shooter of 2018.
my goal is at least 20 people
with an ar-15 and some tracer rounds
it's going to be a big event
and when you see me on the news
you'll know who i am
you're all going to die
i yeah
i can't wait
ah yeah
cold
calculated
manipulative
and deadly
nicholas cruz's defense attorney said
that they will wait until the beginning
of their case in chief to make their
opening statement this sentencing trial
is expected to last four months at the
broward county courthouse i'm angenette
levy for law and crime daily
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney bernardo villalona and forensic
death investigator joseph scott morgan
bernardo what's the most important fact
on both sides for or against the death
penalty that you see in these opening
statements well as of now brian because
you know the defense did not make an
opening statement they chose not to make
an opening statement they want to wait
until the prosecution rest and before
they put on their case to make an
opening statement so as of now we have
heard nothing from the defense in
regards to the prosecution you know that
they have to prove one aggravating
factor beyond a reasonable doubt just
one and the one that stands out to me is
the one where the murder was committed
in a cold calculated and pre-meditated
way and the piece of evidence that's the
strongest is his own words that cell
phone video of him saying i'm going to
be the next school shooter my goal is to
get to kill at least 20 people and that
is damning because it gives us insight
as to what his intent was and what his
mind frame was just days before this
massacre yeah that's an argument i don't
think the defense has a response for
joseph that's the legal aspect but what
should we expect in terms of forensic
evidence in this the penalty phase
it's very important i think from the
prosecution's perspective that they stay
away from the why question defense is
going to chase that all day long and i
think personally it's a red herring
because we know who uh we know what he
did and i think that from the
perspective of the prosecution they're
gonna put we already saw this evidence
today you know they have electronic
experts that were up there kind of
talking about the provenance of uh
taking that server out of there examine
it turn it over to the fbi this sort of
thing we're going to see more of that
we're going to hear ballistic evidence
and we're also unfortunately this is
four months long they're going to talk
about these bodies they're going to talk
about the trauma that this guy inflicted
on these children yeah it's going to be
a long and tragic trial
absolutely but make sure to follow the
law and crime now we'll have gabriel
gabo coverage and of course great
experts like these to break it all down
switching now to south carolina as a man
faces charges after attacking his son's
confessed killer in court
lindy lamont jones confessed to murder
last week pleading guilty to the august
2019 killing of 18 year old willie
antoine fields jones is accused of of
shooting field in the head and three
times in the back willie clay fields the
victim's father attended jones
sentencing hearing a day later the
victim's mother and father asked the
judge to speak as angela fields told the
judge the defendant took away her only
child the slain teen's father darted
from his wife's side took three lunging
steps and appeared to punch jones in the
head and it was all caught on camera
just want to let you know
just what they took from me
they took away my only child
my only child
back up
jones escorted from the courtroom before
his sentence was handed down fields was
brought back in handcuffs and charged
with contempt of court and second-degree
assault and battery
still ahead on law and crime daily a
father and son heads in trial 26 years
after california college student kristen
smart went missing but first new details
in body cam footage released in the rob
elementary school shooting in yuvolka
texas
[Music]
welcome back a preliminary report
released sunday on the evolving texas
school shooting is revealing more
in-depth details about the day and law
enforcement's delayed response in
confronting the gunman
back in may 19 elementary school
students and two teachers were shot and
killed when an 18 year old gunman
entered robb elementary school while
armed investigators say he entered the
school through a propped open door
entered the classroom and began firing
killing over a dozen fourth graders
local police who responded to the
incident came under extreme scrutiny
after it was revealed they waited an
hour before stopping the gunman
surveillance video released last week
gives a glimpse at what happened inside
the school as law enforcement says they
waited for direction the report released
sunday by the texas house committee
investigating the shooting blamed
multiple failures by those in power for
not stopping the massacre the 77-page
report reveals nearly 400 law
enforcement officers including 150 u.s
border patrol agents were on the scene
that day body cam footage was also
released over the weekend showing a
close-up view of the action and inaction
of police response
okay guys
he's on
inside this building we haven't been
contained
he's gonna be
on the building
on the west side of the property careful
with the windows
facing east
right there let me know if there's any
kids in there or anything
this could be peaceful
could you tell me your name anything i
can know please sir if you can hear me
please put your firearm down sir we
don't want anybody else hurt
i know i know we're doing we're trying
to get them out
the police response has been called an
abject failure in the past and here
they're saying that it consisted of
multiple failures so what does this all
mean for all these civil suits that are
coming up
it looks like it's going to be a lot of
settlements that's going to be taking
place because of the multiple failures
that have been revealed and aside from
that what's also going to play a huge
role is that a lot of these officers
were already trained on how to respond
so because they can show prior training
to be ready for an incident like this
every time that they disregarded one of
those trainings that sounds like the
price is going to be much higher in
terms of how much they actually settle
do i see criminal charges here i don't
however that settlement's going to be a
very high settlement amount i'll be
surprised if they have it where it's not
disclosed the settlement amount yeah now
joseph that's kind of big picture but
which one of these things because the
report highlights many flaws and
untruths by the police so which one
sticks out as the most egregious in your
mind
you you can't pull the wool over my eyes
i can actually see them standing there
they got all their operator gear on they
got their ballistic helmets they got
their shield they got their high
velocity rifles you know these ar
platforms that the police officers are
carrying you can see them right there
and for whatever reason they did not run
toward the gunfire and i'm hearing about
keys and all these sorts of things they
go through this high intensity training
they have the ability to breach they can
breach that door and go in and that's
one of the things that you sign up for
whether people realize it or not you run
toward the gunfire we've got all these
babies that are dead now you hear me
talking
that's what's going to happen and there
will be hell to pay but you know what
they're never going to be able to
replace these babies at all yeah i could
have said it better joseph i think that
i'm going to leave it with your words
because
that encapsulates so much in this case
coming up on law on crime daily father
and son paul and reuben flores face a
jury for the first time in the long
awaited trial for the murder and
disappearance of kristin smart
plus kevin dean eastman's defense
attorneys begin presenting their case in
his colorado double homicide trial
[Music]
welcome back opening statements are
presented in the high profile case of
two men charged in the death and
disappearance of kristen smart a
california college student who went
missing 26 years ago paul flores and his
father reuben are charged in connection
with smart's death smart was a student
at california pawlik tech state
university when she went missing in
1996. that year on memorial day weekend
smart was last seen at an off-campus
party with paul a couple days later
smart was reported missing her remains
have never been found but she was
illegally declared dead in 2002. fast
forward 18 years that's when police
searched several homes including rubens
prosecutors aimed to prove smart's body
was buried under a deck in the backyard
of his property but was later moved
investigators say archaeologists found a
soil disturbance as well as the presence
of human blood in the search area paul
was charged with smart's murder while
reuben is charged with accessory after
the fact accused of helping to hide
smart's body a judge has ordered limited
media coverage not allowing broadcast
cameras inside the courtroom only still
photography we will continue to follow
this case here on lawn crime daily as
the trial moves forward
all right joseph help clear this up for
me what would investigators find inside
or like below this deck to make them
believe that a body was there and then
moved and how can i tell who actually
buried the body
yeah this is going to be quite
fascinating to see this is a an area in
forensics that's referred to as forensic
taponomy
where you have a disturbance in the soil
soil commonly is very packed down and
very tight
what they use and i think you saw an
image of it just a second goes ground
penetrating radar and that area that
they kind of go over that area with ryan
go over with that technology they can
tell if there is a soil disturbance i
think that's all fine and good and if
they shore that up with biological
evidence we talked about blood
uh still it's going to be difficult to
get the jury to buy into it and i think
that that's going to be a tough hill for
the prosecution to climb because you
know they want juries want to see a body
they want to see the corpus delecti if
you will it's going to be tough but uh
it's going to be interesting to watch
yeah we'll see how they break that all
down even just what you're putting there
makes it fascinating bernarda does how
long it took please to piece together
this case create any kind of reasonable
doubt that the defense can jump on
well the defense is definitely going to
jump on it because of course during
their closing argument just remember
that the defense has no burden they
don't have to put any evidence forward a
burden lies with the prosecution where
they have to prove the defendant's skill
beyond a reasonable doubt but timing
timing timing timing time does not make
a case stronger if anything it weakens a
case because memories phase evidence
phase so the defense is going to jump on
this and say look my client hasn't left
the country he still lives in this
country he still lives in the very same
state if he would have done something he
would have left so
what took so long yeah if they couldn't
figure it out then why are they figuring
it out now so many other issues again
law and crime daily will be covering
this case even though we can't get
cameras inside puerto rican singer ricky
martin is responding to allegations that
the artist had a sexual and romantic
relationship with a family member martin
was accused of domestic violence earlier
this month and was issued a restraining
order by unnamed victim news outlets had
reported it was not submitted by the
singer's husband and martin's brother
reportedly revealed it was filed by his
21 year old nephew dennis sanchez martin
is denying the new rumors which began
circulating online that he had a sexual
relationship with sanchez for seven
months after it ended martin allegedly
did not take it well his nephew alleges
martin continued to contact him and show
up at his house the lamb pop singer's
attorney says martin has quote never
been and would never be involved in any
kind of sexual or romantic relationship
with his nephew under puerto rico's law
there are harsher penalties for certain
sexual crimes when the alleged victim is
a relative of the accused martin is set
to be in court on thursday
when we come back a man stands trial for
the double murder of his ex-girlfriend
and her lover still ahead of kevin dean
eastman's defense team begins presenting
its case in the colorado tribe
welcome back to law and crime daily in
colorado the defense begins presenting
its case in the double homicide trial
against defendant kevin dean eastman a
man facing charges for the murders of
his ex-girlfriend and her new love
interest two years ago eastman is
charged with two counts of first degree
murder tampering with the deceased human
body and tampering with physical
evidence for allegedly killing heather
frank and local musician stanley scott
sessions on separate days in february of
2020. frank and eastman both had arrest
warrants in connection to sessions
murder before frank's body was found
prosecutors say eastman slit session's
throat inside frank's apartment and that
eastman fatally shot frank in the chest
twice to silence the only witness to
sessions killing they say he then hit
her body near a burn pile on the
property of his new employer
investigators say eastman burned
session's body and was allegedly
preparing to burn frank's body when he
was arrested at a nearby gas station on
friday the defense began its case
calling his first witnesses including
frank's son who told jurors about his
last encounter with his mother which was
after sessions was killed
can you kind of just explain to the jury
how that dinner went that night um
pretty quick to be honest uh it felt
like 45 minutes
um i already ordered my food and my
girlfriend's food
when they came and sat down they ordered
pretty quickly
um
talked for a half hour
uh told her goodbye like love you bye
and
they left let's talk about just the the
general um demeanor or feel of that
dinner first okay i think you started to
talk about it but was there just general
small talk without going into detail
about what was said
um
yes um it was mainly just between me and
my mom and your mom didn't seem any
different to you that night
no not that night no did you know your
mom to be outgoing
yes um did you know her to go out and
about um
concerts or
um
[Music]
see live music
yeah all the time okay
um did she ever mention anything to you
about scott sessions no
and
you also knew of your mom's relationship
with mr eastman yes and you knew that
relationship was rocky
very yes
did you ever know mr eastman to be a
jealous man
no
all right joseph eastman decided not to
testify his constitutional right and the
jury can't hold it against him but do
you think the defense needed him to
explain something to give you reasonable
doubt in this case
no because there's been so much back and
forth in this case and when you consider
the property owner
where
the body was found uh you know earlier
sessions
uh and had been burned this guy keeps
coming up in conversation over and over
and over again i think that the defense
more than likely is just they're they're
probably thinking this is best that
eastman just keep his mouth shut you
know they've they've kind of planted a
seed at least in my opinion of
reasonable doubt because you know
remember this the property owner has
kind of a sketchy past to begin with
they've kind of painted him it's kind of
this this unknown entity among all of
this and that he may have had something
to do with at least that's what the
defense is intimating so i think it's
probably best that eastman not say
anything it's very complex case the less
said the better for them yeah they
definitely planted that scene they'll
see if they can water it during
summations and see how it grows come
verdict time now bernardo what did the
defense's witness do to help the case
and did their testimony push the needle
to guilt or innocence for you
well you know the defense didn't have to
call any witness because the defense
doesn't have the burden however they did
decide to call witnesses and in terms of
the witness that we just learned which
was the victim son she he went around
and saying pretty much killing the
motive of the prosecutor saying that the
motive is because she was cheating and
seeing someone else and that the male
who was killed was actually her lover
but here you have the son saying that he
never mentioned or she never mentioned
anything about this guy and also that mr
eastman is not a jealous guy so it kind
of gives you some kind of insight as to
what her mindset was on that day and
possibly also what was the mindset of mr
eastman but here i don't think that
there was anything that was lost on
behalf of the defense all right let's
see how this goes as you get closer to
them in the case thank you for joining
us here on lawn crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you